let me pull up this story it's from the
daily wire Bill Gates on energy crisis
it's good for the long run the reason I
think this is so important let me give
you a quick bit of context here they say
the billionaire and Microsoft co-founder
explained during an interview with CNBC
that although Global economies cannot
immediately discard oil and gas current
shortages in the European energy Market
will prompt a faster transition away
from fossil fuels quote now without the
Russian natural gas being available in
Europe it's a setback we need to find
non-russian hydrocarbon sources to
substitute for those keeping those
economies in decent shape is a priority
now on the other hand it's good for the
long run because people won't want to be
dependent on Russian natural gas so
they'll move to these new approaches
more rapidly here's the point
for all the people that are very
concerned about climate change and the
environment and all that stuff hey man I
hear you but these people are lying to
you they're saying it's good that
Europe's in an energy crisis right now
Italy they're using Candlelight for
their stores the UK is preparing scripts
this is a guard the guardian reporting
the BBC's preparing these scripts for
when the blackouts hit now so now you've
got in the United States you've got gas
in California at eight bucks you've got
gas on the rise nationally it's over
four it was at four dollars something
right now they're telling you we have to
stop using this stuff because of climate
change and then Joe Biden goes to as you
mentioned Venezuela Saudi Arabia and
just says keep up their production they
clearly still want this stuff their
agenda is it's political and it does not
match what they're saying at home so I
used to be all about like okay you know
let's find renewable energies then I saw
them going overseas to our adversaries
so we're dependent on them okay Bill
Gates can point out we don't want to be
dependent on Russia you know what that
means it means American Energy
Independence it doesn't mean walking
away from and we have it and you know
I'm no fool I'm cognizant I'll be
challenged of course by the EPA and the
buying Administration when I'm governor
next year but we're going to do it
because that's that's that's underneath
the the Constitutional power of the
states the reason why I would say this
is the age of the governors we've seen
we saw during the covet shutdown which
was eye-opening for all of us whether
conservative or not we saw how dangerous
this trend was towards tyranny and
stripping away our freedoms that we just
took for granted we saw Pennsylvania
with very restrictive you know Powers by
Governor wolf and what never was a
governor more appropriately named and
then of course
and then of course Ron DeSantis in
Florida and I kind of say you know this
jokingly but I really do mean it I want
to bring a little bit of Florida to
Pennsylvania as far as freedoms go yeah
but but guys that's not what Bill Gates
wants and what Bill Gates wants is what
Bill Gates gets okay he paid how much
money to the corporate media 250 million
dollars he bought a lot of influence
here he helped spur on the inflation
reduction act which doesn't actually
reduce inflation but we have to
understand here when he's talking about
new approaches he's also talking about
specifically the businesses is that he
has invested in so he's not talking
about energy Independence because of the
United States Drilling and exploring
domestic energy he's talking about
unproven technologies that again have
not been tested most likely are
insufficient a lot of people are calling
them scams and rightfully so and and
when we see this larger problem in the
United Kingdom people will suffer
there's a big potential for a blackouts
people will lose their savings their
money because they're trying to just
afford the ability to heat their homes
and for Bill Gates this is a good thing
for the long run this is his approach
human suffering is good for the long run
if those are your tactics what's going
to be your end game and the end game is
going to be the same thing and the
carbon that he wants to reduce is of
course you Greta tunberg you know how to
tell you if she comes out she says we
got to get off carbon and all that stuff
and I'm sitting here and I'm like okay I
don't like the plastic in the oceans I
don't like the pollution you mentioned
we don't want our trout getting sick I'm
like and I I want clean I want to I want
to go out to the Wilderness on a hike
and see no pollution I don't like when
people throw garbage on the ground and
stuff like that and then I see that
she's not talking about China or India
at all yeah and they're such massive
polluters some of the largest way way
more than the US she doesn't they don't
mention that the U.S actually reduce its
carbon substantially more so than these
other countries they cut down our energy
they drive up our costs they make it
harder for the American working class
and then overseas they ignore what
everyone else is doing they don't ignore
it no no you don't understand it Bill
Gates advises the Chinese government
he's buddies buddies with the Chinese
government so he promotes them the
Chinese government he says on National
Television the Chinese zero covered
approach is the right approach they
should of course create the social
credit score he loves what China's doing
because at the end of the day it's not
about saving the environment that's just
the scam that they have on everyone else
to conjure up a larger power grab all a
part of the Great reset I'll throw you
one of the hardest Hardball questions
ever do you like what China is doing
heck no I'm watching my language this is
the family-friendly show heck no easy
question yeah I I I'm concerned not just
about the the lies in the population I'm
concerned about you know China seems to
be very much invested in US embracing
ideologies that are ripping this country
apart so while they're massively
expanding while their population is much
much larger than ours while they're you
know sinking Vietnamese fishing vessels
they're polluting like crazy their their
cities are so full of smog there's
there's one video of a screen have you
seen this one they have like this big TV
with a sunny day on it because it's just
brown skies yeah and and look I don't
want to see that here but I don't think
any of us are talking about that no
they're Reckless Reckless and
unforgiving they're buying garbage from
from Canada Canada is like we're we're
recycling they're buying it and
literally just dumping it in the ocean
they're not recycling any of it and it's
a scam all of it has been a larger scam
against against the the American people
the people over the world and again Bill
Gates's partnership with China tells you
everything you need to know about it but
it makes you feel good yeah I mean I
know right yeah it's a big PR scam
that's that's the the the big problem
man if you are a moderate liberal or
libertarian minded person and you read
the news and say hey here's a thing they
call you far right in the media yeah if
you like like the big point that I keep
trying to drive drive home here is they
keep saying we got to reduce carbon
whilst actively trying to buy it
overseas while ignoring the carbon being
produced by these other countries
because they're clearly lying you point
that out they say it's a right-wing
talking point yeah apparently China is
building a coal plant almost every week
now I mean is it a violation of these
treaties it is because we're supposed to
sell them I guess a carbon tax or
whatever they're supposed to a certain
limit but for Pennsylvania we become
energy independent and start being a net
exporter and I call it Freedom gas I
mean that that's that's pretty clean
when it burns and it's going to lower
costs in our state what's a so what it's
be cheaper to live here inflation will
go down you have better jobs and and
people want to live in Pennsylvania when
it's funny Bill Gates in his Ivory Tower
literally you know preaching it's a good
thing but he won't be affected he'll
still have his his private jet and his
private cars and his Mansions all with
his job giant carbon footprint you could
take away 90 of his wealth and he's
still a billionaire that's true he has a
lot of beachfront property for someone
who thinks the ocean levels are going to
be rising very soon which is suspicious
and he probably has a bunch of
Apocalypse bunkers he he has he's the
biggest Farmland owner in the United
States he was asked directly hey how
come you don't Institute a lot of your
green policies on your Farms he's like
huh I don't know we don't have to and
I'm like
he just got called out for his hypocrisy
and its hypocrisy after hypocrisy and
Epstein's friend here is not a good
person and he doesn't have your best
interest at heart well so let me ask you
when you're talking a lot about energy
uh natural gas is that specifically what
you're able to person you're talking
everything I'm talking about the three
levels and Remy and I have been out to a
natural grass uh natural gas grass grass
is good too like that good for the cats
Freedom gas that's easy for me to say uh
rig out in Western PA but so three
levels natural gas is massive in a
marcelo's shell and we have uh We've
viewed how they extract it it is safe
the water tables aren't being polluted
they actually put a um a concrete uh
filter in to block our aquifers from
being contaminated from this proprietary
formula to use extracted and then of
course colon oil the oil is very high
grade I mean it's the kind of stuff that
you use in an important Machinery any
thoughts on this I think they said they
could if um they had a um whey a plant
in Pennsylvania they could actually turn
that into gas for the cars as well it's
yes rubby's right and so I was talking
with one of the energy producers and
he's like all we need is a refinery in
Pennsylvania and we can turn our natural
gas to automobile gas I'm like you've
got to be kidding me let's do that
gasoline gasoline natural gas into
gasoline methane into gasoline I don't
know I didn't ask them for the details
and I just said let's do that have you
have you heard about uh I think Ian
brought this up was it you that they
they turned plastic into uh diesel yeah
um they found like a deoxygenated high
pressure high temperature environments
you can melt plastic back into oil it
needs to be refined in a gasoline but
it's that's it's going to become a
valuable commodity is recovering the
plastic yeah what do you think about
stuff like that are would you be
interested as governor in exploring ways
to other places we have this stuff
sitting around in the garbage heaps
stinking up I mean in the oceans let's
let's use it that way you can also
upcycle coal into graphene which is like
I don't know if you're familiar with
graphene
yeah everyone drink 21st century
Building Material it's like steel more
conductive than copper that's like a
capacity every capacitor like a battery
um it's a pure carbon what do you do you
like take two sheets of it and you twist
it or something like you do twistronic
graphene you can take multiple sheets of
it and they're putting it layering it on
top of each other one point uh there's
1.13 degrees uh eventually they're being
super conductive carbon it's this it's a
powder here yeah this is pure carbon for
sure and you can hit coal with lasers
and turn it into this stuff and then it
burns cleaner and then you can turn it
into building materials wiring and
what's going to happen by 2029 it'll be
globally
uh this will become the new it'll be
adopted essentially Peak graphing 2012.
so if we get on it now and we start
producing this stuff early let's let's
Ohio University is working on the
upscaling of coal pretty heavily into
graphene I would love Pennsylvania to
take the lead on something like that
check this out Ian Ian brought this up
uh so Ian's thing is graphing you know
when he's graph Ian uh but graphene is
oh he's writing it down Ian he got one
so but here's something really
interesting that Ian brought up
at the turn of the century in um the
1800s 1900s in New York they said that
there's going to be horse manure horse
manure piling 10 feet high the city will
be unlivable it'll smell then the car
got invented and there was no horse
manure at all it was gone but there was
a lot at the time Ian brings up a good
point that we're talking about global
warming with carbon in the atmosphere
but they have carbon capture technology
that can pull carbon and they can mine
it from the air to produce a a material
like graphene so when we're talking
about all this climate change stuff it
really does feel like people are
discounting human invention that we
might actually as Ian points out
have too little carbon in the atmosphere
at that point when we start complaining
about it it's getting too cold we'll be
able to what you withdraw the carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere you can
deposit it on the metals and then turn
it into graphene the carbon you strip
the carbon out of the carbon dioxide you
can also take methane out of the
atmosphere turn it into carbon dioxide
and then turn it into graphene what's
going to happen is we're going to create
an industry where we're mining the air
and then we're going to start competing
with trees for carbon dioxide so we've
got to be real careful about The Way We
Set This Global industry in sand burn
more gas wow got to burn more it's not a
bad idea if you can capture the carbon
right out of the Smoke Stack that I
think is ideal because you're not
introducing but at the same time we got
to start cleaning up what's already out
there too I love it especially since
we're the second largest producer of
Hardwoods uh in the in the North America
so we got to balance that that's for
sure that's amazing what about
sustainability I mean can this this
can't last forever is there a timetable
on how long so I I looked at a report
and obviously there's a lot of
geological interpretation here they're
saying we have about two or three
centuries worth of energy underneath our
feet in Pennsylvania wow yeah but
whatever what what about two or three
centuries later
by then we're using Fusion Energy by
then we have graphene and we have we
have Mr Fusion on the back of our cars
like in Back to the Future thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there